I will never get anything over and over
what is this
cry today Rhea and I are gonna be
playing a little game
Rhea has to cook a dish but she has no
idea what that dish is I have to give
her instructions using these recipe
cards but here's a little catch there
are a bunch of words on here that are
completely off-limits let's see what
we're making okay we're gonna be making
creamy chicken piccata all right ray
come on are you ready for this I don't
know I'm gonna tell you the rules for
the game avoid the off-limits were no
miming while speaking the cook can only
do as instructed as any rules are broken
the instructor can only mime the next
step let's go play okay this one's
pretty simple bring a large pot of
[Music]
seasoned water to a boil
okay I'm assuming you got this one yeah
seasoned water salt right ding ding ding
so there it's to white thing wine salt
wine sugar but this is salt just like
make sure it's yes
oh we don't want sugar yeah I also ate
pasta because it's large pot of water
seasoned with salt so and also I want to
use lid because it's like faster the
process I can just put another pan on
top of crafty I didn't actually
technically tell you to do that okay
okay
mm-hmm next prepare the chicken yeah
okay I feel like I'm pretty good at this
all right I buy actually mines that so
the next card I cannot see can I just
kind of tough hard make my life easier
so chicken okay let me ask you a
question how big it's a chicken is it
cute easy like why are you crying
lie cop butterfly cow
bought the fly cup per Frankie place on
top of a piece of you color in the in
kindergarten you color Mahoney a gun
that's a anyone have a string go Sunday
like I really don't get the paper so why
do you use for bake baking paper yeah
so place on top a piece of chicken the
paper okay
I can't use words yeah all the crew
should be mom I think you're better at
my good
I have no idea what I'm making could you
let me boil water
pounding chicken I think pounding
chicken means I feel like we're gonna
roll so I feel like I should go a little
thinner no thicker thinner spin 1/2 inch
1/2 1/2 1/2 inch 1/2 1/2 I will never
get a yo-yo same thing over and over say
well so pound until this sides this
thickness oh okay
do the hand and we see
[Music]
okay a quarter in season well with salt
and pepper
I think our water is ready pit burn
lightly coat each piece of chicken with
not that's a made of gluten include
their flour
yeah next keep a metal thing Pam uh-huh
over medium heat okay so let me wash my
hands before I'm getting pun did I say
you could do that you mind it
luckily I already have a pan warmed up
add-in shoot add in the greasy oil olive
oil okay how much oh it's all measured
out okay fry the chicken in the pan
until it has like a nice tan golden
brown don't gesture don't do this now
she's telling me what to do you need to
discard the chicken once cup chicken
grease discard just like so once it's
become golden brown take the chicken out
old from the past yes pour in the stuff
that I drink every weekend wine I know
who you - well actually you didn't
clarify which type of wine white wine
thinking I mean then I just pour it and
at unknown the he because he has a lot
of oil and he's gonna spotter it smells
really good so how long am i producing
wait that was the next step
yourself hurry up add in see one of my
favorite foods so I'm big that's that
you believe
put in a biscuit stop you put a butter
next you're going to add in my other
favorite food
chupa more cream when I'm gonna be
making out I don't eat this garlic and
little round things paper part in the
the stuff I used to sell on the sidewalk
as kid cupcake lemonade
okay so lemon not lemonade there was one
time that I did sell lemon juice
actually I forgot to put the sugar oh my
god we're not add in the bok-bok-bok
chicken juice chicken juice chicken
stock yeah chicken stock what's this
I think it's a beef maybe you got a
smell yeah
chicken stock is reduced what's next
next you're gonna stir in the stuff that
comes out of a cow udder milk no heavy
milk okay yeah there is two things look
like milk and heavy heavy cream
YUM there's a Star Wars movie called
and buy a strike buck different one
give me another hint blank of the Jedi
baton yeah but turn the chicken to the
pan okay that was a good one good job
Alex
so now we're going to cook what am I
Alex I'm a complete woman I'm just a
girl from heaven from heaven
angel cook Oh angel hair pasta used to
be my favorite kind of pasta because I
always thought I had kind of like angel
like hair look like angel hair
faster thing for two a minute
waiting you don't need these Tomatoes
figure it's easy I'll snap an appetizer
yeah do you want to make a little salad
for me I've done yet Bri I'm next you're
going to hmm tell me do you a little
things color can't say it
hello of leprechauns Oh green give me
more
it's the opposite of cilantro PAH sorry
well I knew I actually just got a little
carried away there I still don't know
what's this
okay we have the one final command from
the angel you have to baby Salam one
bite you don't have the following day
put it on the thing that's round and you
kind of know you have a view in your
kitchen plate I take all the credit for
making this delicious I still don't know
what's this you know I think there's
like veal Picatta
chicken piccata so we've reached the
best part of the game it's time to eat
taste this now VA if this is bad you are
taking full responsibility
this is good it's all on me okay we a
hakuna piccata big in chess oh wow my
piece is so cool
that's me my me so I'm this recipe it's
soft and fauna easy when we started it
was Anna bumpy start but we made a
delicious dish so this recipe is
actually live on tasty so if you want to
make this yourself go check it out I'm
sorry I can't be there with you to tell
you how high five
catch you later can I mine you don't
need to I can just like mine when do you
say